les chéris bien sûr si elle bat ce qui
va arriver dans un instant et c'est vrai
que j'avais une question à vous poser
parce que on est tous même famille et en
ce moment on le voit le public est là
qui pour vous dans le métier le gars
votre gars sûr c'est à dire le mec vous
savez que vous allez à la paix à
n'importe quelle heure c'est votre cas
sur ces votre pote craig beaumont c'est
sur lui répond c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
moi vu que dans le métier je connais pas
trop devenait trop tard trop d'artistes
monga sur ce je pense que ce sera vous
finalement avec plaisir parce que depuis
dix ans on m'avait pas lâché j'ai
toujours pu compter sur vous donc je
pense que je serai pas à montreuil manga
sur dans le métier bas et franchement tu
peux compter sur mambo charge et
vraiment je serai toujours là pour toi
c'est cool et et aeris je te lis je me
suis pas trompé parce que je le déçois
pas vraiment mon chéri à ça va venir est
très fière de toi voilà c'est ça
vraiment vraiment je suis fier d'eux
raymond parce que j'avais misé sur lui
avec le rapido que mon poids que s'il
avait présenté que le patron de
réflexion qu un type génial on est
vraiment et miser sur raymond on a misé
sur aimons et raymond tu nous a pas
déçus parce qu'on s'est pas trompé havas
et a vraiment beaucoup de talent et tu
nous déçoit pas rené c qui toi l'om
non non moi j'étais lui la vérité j'ai
un ami à marseille lam et un corps
soient d'accord ici voilà on fait appel
il s'appelle charles en tout cas je
connais pas bien sombre et à marseille
il ya mon ami gérard vallet il y en a
qui viennent de faire un cadeau de se
voir celer à isabelle wave if and when
forme
voilà merci isabelle céline mal oui
c'est une balle et baca bien une balle
pour une meuf qui n'est pas dedans oui
dedans il ya un petit truc corail donc
c'est le trou noir
c'est votre cas sur et ben moi j'ai bien
d'emmerder les gens mais je pense que si
j'appelais mairie mais le jour où j'ai
un gros ennui elle serait toujours
fabuleux je laime mireille ouais j'aime
toute la famille et une mireille de plus
amples et chiappucci métier longtemps
l'appel quoi je les adore c'est
quelqu'un avec qui je suis tout le temps
désaccord mais qui est toujours là dans
les moments difficiles c'est pascal
praud a passé votre pote toujours là
quand il ya quelque chose qui va pas on
peut l'appeler là il
ils rappellent ils est présent donc
j'aime beaucoup pour sa cabine alors on
a les mêmes horaires et il a les
conseils de l'ancien avec un esprit de
jeune ces gens me sens c'est vrai que
c'est et non plus à la bien résumé
jean-louis six mois ce serait mathieu
mathieu delormeau mais répond pas s'ils
répondent pas toujours
alors que vous c'est vrai que je ne veux
pas faire le fayot comme comme raymond
mais quand vous envoie un message on
voit un problème jean-mi il ya quelque
chose de grave tout de suite par seconde
c'est la famille non mais c'est vrai
j'ai souvent dit que c'était mon
deuxième papa je suis plus vieux mais
vous êtes en mai mais j'aime j'adore
quand vous dites ça ça me fait que c'est
vrai je le pense dit je ne pense
vraiment très bien en plus allégé le
betis benjamin se serait foucault
jean-pierre j'aurais pu venir jouer en
fait je serais fou voilà bah moi aussi
je fais un mec un qui a un coeur en or
il est disponible et ça fait une 25 ans
30 ans que le poney et c'est vraiment un
mec extraordinaire je suis un peu
d'accord donc c'est franchement d'aller
dans les big star de l'animation
je pense qu'ils les voyez vraiment dans
les plans et 3 plus c'est un amour est
quand même cher aussi drucker pas qu'on
embrasse à lui s'est plaint philippe
ouais moi j'ai de la chance d'avoir de
très bons amis mais s'il faut en choisir
deux ce que je vais en choisir deux
c'est gérard darmon
bien sûr bien sûr cela doré mans que
j'embrasse et que aussi je l'embrassé
qui est exceptionnel girac iem forêt qui
m'a rendu je vous dis girard je
n'oublierai jamais j'avais lancé une
nouvelle émission sur canal plus et où
c'était pas du tout rencontrer je vais
dire gérard est ce que tu vas être
premiers invités
il m'a dit tu sais quoi je le sens bien
je vais venir ça a été une merveille et
j'aime vraiment ce mec voilà je suis
fait un gros bide amos
non